c'était il ya dix ans un jour pour jour
l'annnonce de barack obama de la forme
mission de combat de l'armée américaine
en irak
elle lancé en 2003 par l'ex président
george w bush l'opération a coûté la vie
à plus de 4400 soldats américains retour
en images sur le retrait progressif des
troupes américaines en irak
[Musique]
e
et un retrait des troupes très
symbolique les américains ne sont plus
les maîtres du jeu en irak c'est en tout
cas l'avis de pierre conesa ancien haut
fonctionnaire au ministère de la défense
et spécialiste des questions
stratégiques et internationales
d'abord là que c'était plus symbolique
que réelle puisque effectivement barack
obama voulait revenir en arrière sur des
décisions prises par les républicains et
les conservateurs qui comme vous le
savez sont très belliciste et donc il a
effectivement retirer une partie de ses
troupes mais les conditions locales ont
obligé à laisser un contingent qui est
quand même pas si pas négligeable je
crois qu'il a encore trois mille soldats
sur place le bilan et acier assez
déplorable d'abord parce que
l'intervention a détruit un pays et
ensuite parce que le retrait si vous
voulez est un peu le symbole de l'échec
de toutes ces interventions militaires
qu'on a décroché un peu partout on finit
une période qui était celle de
l'unilatéralisme absolue qui s'est
ouverte à 91 après la chute de l'urss et
dans lesquels tout le courant
néo-conservateur américain avait essayé
de creuser tous les moyens possibles
pour que la suprématie américaine
exclusive continue à régner sur la
planète
les occidentaux n'ont aucun levier de
commande pour intervenir dans une crise
qu'ils ont créé donc on est dans cette
situation aujourd'hui vous avez de
nouveaux acteurs qui interviennent en
irak au coeur du sein et c'est dans un
moment de retrait militaire des
occidentaux c'est-à-dire pour
l'essentiel des intervenants turcs et
russes situation extrêmement nouvelle
évidemment quand vous l'imaginez